hey everyone it's sarah thruster nurse
orion comm and today we're going to go
over the most common labs you need to
know for the NCLEX exam and as a nurse
so whenever you get done watching this
youtube video don't forget to access the
free quiz that will test you on these
lab values so let's get started when you
take the NCLEX exam there is a high
probability that you're going to
encounter some type of lab value
question and the reason for this is
whenever you're working as a nurse
especially in a hospital almost every
patient that walks through that door is
going to have blood work performed
because the blood work tells us what's
going on with our patient and how we can
care for them
so in clicks is going to really hit on
those common labs that you're going to
be experiencing on a daily basis on the
job so what are they well a CBC a
complete blood count this tells us about
the cells in our blood like our red
blood cells white blood cells platelets
all those important cells that help us
maintain life
in addition arterial blood gases ABG's
this tells us the acid-base imbalance in
our patients especially for patients
having a respiratory or metabolic
problem it can tell us how bad it is and
if our treatment is working to help
correct the problem another thing is
metabolic panels this can be a basic
like a BMP or comprehensive like a cmp
and this tells us really important
things like our patient's fluid and
electrolyte status how's our potassium
our sodium or calcium glucose along with
our patient's renal function their bu in
and creatinine and if it's comprehensive
it can tell us how that liver is
performing as well another thing you
want to know especially if your patients
on anticoagulants are their Co AG levels
their coagulation levels like that
pt/inr aPTT
and this is going to tell us how our
patient's clotting what's their claudine
time and if their therapeutic on their
medication and lipid panels this is
assessing the patient's cardiovascular
risk for disease and we're looking at
the LD
the HDL the total cholesterol and
triglycerides and the last thing are
those drug levels because patients many
of our patients are on drugs that have
this narrow therapeutic level like
digoxin dilantin lithium and we want to
know is it safe to give this drug what's
their drug level now when you take the
ink Lexx exam and you're looking at
those lab values and you're trying to
determine is this normal or abnormal you
need to know that NCLEX is going to give
you something that is noticeably
abnormal it's not going to be right on
the line or close to the normal range
and the reason for that is because lab
ranges for the normal really vary
depending on the lab and the text like
for instance some things will say that a
normal mag is one point five to two
point three while another one may say
it's one point five to two point five so
inc Lex is going to give you something
that's really abnormal and you're gonna
know it's abnormal so first let's start
out talking about the complete blood
count the CBC this tells us about the
cells in our blood so what a normal RBC
range a red blood cell range it should
be four point five to five point five
million for white blood cells WBC's it
should be five thousand to ten thousand
for platelets it should be a hundred and
fifty thousand to four hundred thousand
now some terms you want to be familiar
with would be like thrombocytopenia what
is that that is a low platelet count so
they say that to you you know that's
gonna be less than a hundred and fifty
thousand or how about a patient with
leukopenia that is a low white blood
cell count so i count less than five
thousand now let's look at our
hemoglobin and hematocrit levels this
tells us about our red blood cells and
we really use this when we're
transfusing packed red blood cells we
want to know that hemoglobin level
really and it varies between the female
and the male and I would remember the
differences for a female a normal
hemoglobin range is twelve to sixteen
grams per deciliter a normal whom a
decree is 37 to 47 percent and for a
male a normal hemoglobin is 14 to 18
grams per deciliter and a normal
hematocrit is 42 to 52 percent now let's
look at coagulation levels if your
patients on an anticoagulant you
definitely want to know their
coagulation levels for instance if
they're on warfarin you want to know
their PT on R and if they're on heparin
you want to know that a PTT so let's
look at this PT on our PT sands for
prothrombin time and a normal PT level
and someone who's not on any
anticoagulant should be 10 to 12 seconds
an INR is calculated from the PT and I
know R stands for international
normalized ratio and normally it should
be less than 1 and this is for someone
who's not taking any anticoagulants
specifically warfarin but how long they
are taking warfarin what are we 1 2 on
our level 2 B so their therapeutic so
this drug is working to prevent blood
clots we would wonder inr to be between
2 to 3 so if it's less than 2 this
coumadin this warfarin is not really
achieving what we need so their dose
would need to be increased if it was way
greater than 3 they are at risk for
bleeding so their dose would need to be
decrease now let's look at this a PTT
this stands for activated partial
thromboplastin time and this is used to
for patients who are taking heparin a
normal a PTT in a patient who's not
taking heparin is 30 to 40 seconds now
they're taking heparin we need them to
be within this certain range so their
therapeutic and this drug is working so
we would want it to be one and a half to
two and a half times this normal range
with which ends up being about 60 to 80
seconds now if they were less than 60
that would mean that we're not achieving
what we need they're not therapeutic so
their dose would need to be increase
of heparin if they're greater than 80
seconds it's taking them way too long to
clot so they really have too much
heparin in their system so their dose
would need to be decreased now let's
switch and let's look at the metabolic
panel again this is going to tell us
about our fluid and electrolytes which
will include glucose our renal function
and if it's comprehensive it's gonna
tell us how our liver is functioning as
well so let's look at these ranges ok
glucose a normal glucose is 70 to 100
milligrams per deciliter calcium level
is eight point five to ten point five
milligrams per liter chloride is 95 to
105 million equivalent per liter
magnesium is one point five to two point
five milligrams per deciliter phosphorus
is two point five to four point five
milligrams per deciliter potassium is 3
point 5 to 5 milli equivalents per liter
and a sodium is 135 to 140 5 milli
equivalents per liter now how I remember
those is that they're like multiples of
5 like everything is represented with 5
so if you can read over that it'll help
keep you straight now let's look at our
renal function our bu in and creatinine
will tell us that normal bu in is 5 to
20 a normal creatinine is point six to
one point two milligrams per deciliter
now we're getting into liver function so
let's look at total protein that is six
point two to eight point two grams per
deciliter and then albumin this is
another protein remember I'll be even
quite a huge role in regulating our
oncotic pressure and it's three point
four to five point four grams per
deciliter then we have these three
enzymes that are found in the liver
it's the ALP the alt and the ast and if
these are abnormal it could indicate
liver disease or some type of other
disease in the body so a normal ALP
which stands for alkaline phosphatase is
40 to 120 units per liter then we have
alt which stands
for Abilene transaminase and a normal
range of seven 256 units per liter and
then the ast which is aspartate
transaminase a normal is ten to forty
units per liter then the last part of
our metabolic panel is the Billy Ruben
and this substance is created when you
have the breakdown of red blood cells
and when the red blood cells break down
they release this reddish orangish color
and a normal bilirubin level should be
less than one milligrams per deciliter
but if your patient has an elevated one
you will notice that they will have this
orangish yellowish hue to their skin or
this mucous membrane where all this
bilirubin has collected in the blood and
has just leaked into the skin giving
them that like pumpkin hue appearance
now let's look at the lipid panel this
test is going to tell us about our
patient's risk for cardiovascular
disease and it's going to look at the
LDL to HDL the total cholesterol and the
triglycerides so LDL this stands for
low-density lipoprotein and we want this
value to be low so we want it to be less
than a hundred milligrams per deciliter
now the HDL which stands for high
density lipoprotein we want this number
to be high and we want it greater than
60 milligrams per deciliter so some
people get these confused by how I
remember it
is that l4 LDL stands for low so we want
that number low and the HDL it stands
for high so we want this number high now
total cholesterol we want that less than
200 milligrams per deciliter and then
triglycerides less than a hundred and
fifty milligrams per deciliter now let's
move on to arterial blood gases
ABG's I have a whole video on how to
interpret ABG so now if its respiratory
metabolic problem if it's acidosis
alkalosis compensation partial
compensation and check out that video
because it'll show you how to do the
tic-tac-toe method and really simplify
how to get those answers but you want to
know the normal ranges for those so a
blood pH is seven point three five
seven points four or five anything less
than seven point three five is acidic
anything greater than seven point four
five is alkaline then we have a PCO to
the normal range but four that is 35 to
45 and I have switched them here because
anything greater than 45 is acidic and
anything less than 35 is alkaline then
we have bicarb hco3 the normal range is
22 to 26 and anything less than 22 is
acidic and anything greater than 26 is
alkaline then we have po2 which normal
is 80 to a hundred percent and then we
have oxygen saturation and a normal is
about 96 95 to a hundred percent now
let's switch to the hemoglobin a1c test
this test is really helpful in helping
us determine the average glucose in a
person over the last three months so
it's great for patients who have
diabetes so we can see their average
glucose so what do we want this number
to be well in a person who does not have
diabetes we would want them to have a
hemoglobin a1c of four to six percent
but if they have diabetes we would like
for their target hemoglobin a1c to be
less than seven percent now let's wrap
up this lecture and let's talk about the
most common drug levels you may
encounter on NCLEX so first up is
digoxin a normal digital is 0.5 to two
nanograms per milliliter then we have
carbamazepine which is tegretol normal
level is four to ten micrograms per
milliliter dilantin a normal level is 10
to 20 micrograms per milliliter
then theophylline normal level same as
dilantin is 10 to 20 micrograms per
milliliter then we have phenobarbital a
normal level is 15 to 40 micrograms per
milliliter lithium at 0.5 to 1.2
millimoles per liter and then lastly
valproic acid also known as depakote it
is 52
micrograms per milliliter okay so that
wraps up this review over the most
common lab values you need to know for
the ink Lex exam thank you so much for
watching don't forget to take the free
quiz and to subscribe to our channel for
more videos